they're calling this Joe mentum a
campaign that appeared beaten a week ago
now suddenly resurgent former vice
president with the White House firmly in
his sights we are very much alive and
make no mistake about it this campaign
will send Donald Trump packing it is a
relief for his supporters who believe he
is the only Democrat who can appeal even
to moderate Republicans and independents
and beat Donald Trump just now as a
party we're coming together and seems we
the best one to take on Trump is
[Music]
revolution we did that once
and it's really time to restore America
to the greatness that it actually was
before Trump tried to be the golfing
leader in chief two and a half thousand
miles away the man who's been the
front-runner for weeks now is still a
powerful force but Bernie Sanders knows
he's in a fight now you're cannot beat
Trump with the same old same old
kind of politics
what we need is a new politics that
brings working-class people into a
political movement and which in November
will create the highest voter turnout in
American political history for half a
billion dollars of his own money in TV
ads the former New York Mayor Michael
Bloomberg had hoped to turn this into a
three horse race he hasn't and is now
reassessing his campaign how many
delegates we win tonight we have done
something no one else thought was
possible in just three months we've gone
from 1% of the polls to being a
contender for the Democratic nomination
for president
to add to his misery Donald Trump
tweeted that Bloomberg was the biggest
loser of the night millions down the
drain he wrote and the destruction of
his reputation hopes that this would be
Elizabeth Warren's moment also failed to
materialize it is now a choice between
liberal one offered by Bernie Sanders
[Music]
talked to Democrats across the country
and they'll tell you only one thing
really matters beating Donald Trump in
November and maybe Joe Biden is their
hope after all Gregg Milam Sky News Los
Angeles